so T foo is suing faze clan now you guys
have probably already seen the drama
videos on this and you've already heard
the rumors on Twitter but we're here to
cut through the [ __ ] and figure out
what's actually going on in this video
I'm gonna go over what the lawsuit
really says what phase bank said and
what phase claim themselves said so get
ready because we've got a big mess to
clean up here
[Music]
okay so let's start at the beginning
this whole thing actually started in
September of last year when T Fu's
lawyers sent letters to faze clan trying
to get his contract with them terminated
after they allegedly breached it by not
paying him money they apparently owed
it's worth noting here that according to
the recent lawsuit faze clan disputed
that letter and did not obviously
release T foo from his contract so here
we are on May 20th 2019 T Fu's lawyers
sued faze clan the lawsuit starts by
outlining what T foo actually is he's
not just a gamer a competitive Fortnight
player he's a content creator he's an
artist and it reminds us and everyone
else reading it that there is no
governing body or union or guild that
covers content creators in the eSports
or streaming or twitch space there's no
one here to keep them from being
exploited
now the lawsuit does take on the tone of
a sort of white knight defense of
content creators in the eSports space a
little on but first let's outline what T
Fu's beef with faze clan according to
the lawsuit actually is now the lawsuit
starts out by alleging that faze clan is
trying to port on quote own T foo they
refer to his contract bizarrely as a
gamer agreement and they call it quote
grossly oppressive onerous and one-sided
and and this is key here folks the
lawsuit alleges that faze clan is
entitled to 80% of the quote revenue
paid by third parties for 10 e services
end quote
that would be turner 10 e AKA t foo now
let's pause for a second and talk about
this 80% number this is the figure that
everyone seems to have misunderstood or
misconstrued it does not allege that
faze clan was entitled to or took 80
percent of his YouTube money of his
twitch sub money of any social media
monies what it does mean is that if t
foo participates in a third party
endorsement deal faze clan is entitled
to take 80 percent of the revenue from
that deal now when this story broke it
seemed like a lot of people including
keemstar and actually faze banks himself
completely misunderstood this number and
this fact did anyone actually read the
lawsuit the lawsuit also alleges that
faze clan is actually acting illegally
by limiting T through to only third
party deals that they
broker and they approve it says faze
clan is acting as a talent agency even
though they don't have a license to do
so in the state of California so what
does this actually mean well it means
that if T food goes to Pepsi and says
hey I want to do an endorsement deal for
a billion dollars in Pepsi says yeah
sure let's do it faze clan can say ah
sorry man we actually already have a
deal with coca-cola of which we are
entitled to 80% here's your 20% the
lawsuit also alleges that faze clan owes
him money even from those 80/20 deals
somewhere in the past which as we just
discussed are allegedly illegal in the
first place the lawsuit does go on to
claim that faze clan also violated their
fiduciary duty to T foo which just means
an ethical duty to the guy by vetoing
certain third party deals that he
brokered the lawsuit specifically
mentions a deal that t foo supposedly
set up with hyper X that faze clan
quashed probably in conflict with their
SteelSeries agreement to quote the
lawsuit itself faze clan is allegedly
acting against T Fu's best interest in a
quote willful wanton an oppressive way
as far as the drama goes you guys
probably heard this part already but
there is a line in the lawsuit that
alleges that faze clan also pressured
young 20 and 21 year old T foo to
underage drink to gamble and to
participate in quote dangerous stunts
it's worth noting that faze banks one of
the original founders of faze clan
refutes the claims about underage
drinking gambling and stunts and saying
he was doing all of that stuff before or
independently of faze clan
homie what Turner we all know you're a
[ __ ] sicko
jump off of [ __ ] you've been doing that
far far far before you met us so
basically the lawsuit claims and claims
is the key word here guys that T foo got
[ __ ] by an unfair and straight-up
illegal contract and that BAE's clan
allegedly failed to honor even that T
foo wants out of his gamer agreement his
contract he wants any money that still
owed to him and through the lawsuit he
is seeking damages which just means some
extra money for all the [ __ ] that
he's allegedly gone through the lawsuit
also tries to paint itself as sort of a
white knight champion for content
creators rights
saying that it wants to quote shift the
balance of power to the gamers and
content creators / streamers those
who are actually creating value and
driving the industry it also says that
it even hopes this lawsuit will help
quote clean up eSports ok that was a lot
about the lawsuit and about t food but
we needed to clear the air so those are
the three major points that the lawsuit
that's filed against faze clan is
alleging now faze clan and faze banks
did respond so let's get to their side
of the story faze clan released an
initial statement very quickly after the
lawsuit went public on twitter saying
that they took zero money from his prize
winnings zero money from his YouTube
zero money from his twitch and zero
money from his other social media
platforms here's the problem as we went
over in the last section that's not what
the lawsuit alleges at all nowhere in
the lawsuit filed on behalf of t food
does it claimed that faze clan took or
is entitled to any of those things faith
claim claims that they've only made
sixty thousand dollars in total off t
foo while he has made in their own words
millions then faze clan released another
statement based on all the confusion
around the eighty percent in the sixty
thousand dollar number and they do
confirm what the lawsuit alleges insofar
as faze clan is entitled to eighty
percent of revenue deals for third-party
sponsorships they say they've just never
acted on those rights they claimed that
t foo was signed to an older version of
the faze clan contracts that was drafted
by an outdated legal team with outdated
legal language and that new contracts in
faze clan looked different faze clan
claims they've been trying to actually
renegotiate that old contract with t
food since last september which if you
remember is when his lawyers initially
sent those letters trying to get him out
of his contract so that was the official
lawsuit and the official response from
faze clan to the lawsuit here's where
things get messy
soon after this whole thing broke faze
banks took to twitter took to youtube
and released some very emotionally
charged pieces of writing and video
content he said he was blindsided and
quote in absolute shock and quote he
lamented the fact that chief of himself
didn't contact him before filing the
lawsuit he called nadeshot a quote piece
of [ __ ] end quote
for weighing in on the situation and
called t Fu's lawsuit quote disgusting
lies on lies saying I'm [ __ ] hurting
right now he later went on to say quote
[ __ ]
professional and quote well yeah he's
obviously very emotional about the
situation and his reactions are clearly
raw and clearly authentic he even says
he and Teague have a close personal
relationship that they're friends he
actually has teeth whose name tattooed
on his body I'm sorry guys I'm [ __ ]
flustered man like have this kid's name
tattooed on my [ __ ] leg
like imagine how dumb I feel right now
he came out of the gate pretty quickly
to deny some of the perceived
allegations against faze clan saying
that they never took 80 percent of his
prize winnings or his YouTube money or
his twitch money which once again is not
what the lawsuit actually says these
banks also alleges that the main
motivational driver behind this whole
lawsuit is probably not Tipu himself but
rather his father or his brother now I
don't know either way I'm not Tifa when
I'm not in faze clan and I don't think
at the end of the day it particularly
matters now one of the key points I want
us all to remember on the faze clan side
of things when it comes to this whole
drama is that both in the faze clan
official statement and in bankses
personal video called dirty foo they
allege that they've been trying to work
with tee foo to redefine the terms of
his contract since last September and
that that work has been met with pure
rejection or utter silence now it's
worth noting at this juncture that tee
foo popped off in terms of sub count
popularity and overall visibility after
joining faze clan that's obviously no
surprise now would he have gone to where
he is now without faze clan well he's
still the best fortnight player may be
the best gamer in the world so yeah I
think he would have would he have got
here as fast without faze clan
I doubt did faze clan benefit from their
relationship with tee foo certainly they
did maybe not from money directly
collected from the man himself but from
sponsorship deals and brand activations
that came from having T foo on their
team essentially what I'm saying here is
that up until now both parties have
benefitted greatly from their
relationship a few days after the whole
controversy broke t foo himself broke
his silence and released a brief
two-minute video in which he said that
the claims of
under age gambling underage drinking and
dangerous stunts would be taken out of
the lawsuit he also made a pretty
serious demand of faze clan show the
[ __ ] contract this release the
[ __ ] contract BAE's banks immediately
responded saying that BAE's clan were
going to do just that release t Fu's
contract in full to the public so why is
t food doing this why is the king of
twitch suing faze clan to get out of a
contract he signed last year because at
the end of the day that's what it's
really about it's about getting out of
the contract it's not about the damages
he's suing for and it's not about the
alleged unpaid wages from sponsorship
deals it's about being able to spread
his wings free of face clamps it seems
to me that this 21 year old man who has
found himself to be the best most
successful gamer in the world period and
stopped has discovered that after
signing a contract at 20 years old he's
become bigger than the organisation he
signed with he is bigger than faze clan
t foo is bigger than fortnight he's
bigger than battle Royales he has in
total a three and a half year contract
with faze clan there was an initial six
months and after that an additional 36
months that means he has over two years
left two years is a very long time in
eSports it's a very long time in
streaming in two years fortnight might
not be around anymore or at least not
the top of the heap in two years t fool
might be getting movie deals he might
have his own record label whatever
massive opportunities come his way in
the next two years and beyond
he doesn't want an 80/20 split of
anything he wants a 100 0 140 foo and
zero for anybody else but it's not just
about the money it's about having total
control of T foo and what that name
represents it's about being able to make
any decision he deems worthy without
faze clan saying yay or nay I find this
situation really fascinating not because
of the drama not because of the tweets
and the videos but because of the
implications this lawsuit
could have on the contracts of future
entertainers in our space in the eSports
space in twitch in streaming in general
in gaming in general if this lawsuit
goes to court and maybe even if it
doesn't it could change the game so to
speak for entertainers in our sphere
this whole video was meant to be an
explainer to set the record straight for
you guys so you could cut through the
[ __ ] now when and if this lawsuit
goes to court we will have more content
for you and we'll be there to help make
sense of it with you until then if you
have any further questions if you guys
think this wasn't clear at all if you
don't understand the lawsuit or anything
we said in this video I'd actually love
to hear from you in the comment section
and we can reply and help clear
everything up for once at me thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]